uh Ronaldo is able to rewrite Sharia law
instead of having to marry his
girlfriend that's fire Yeah inshallah so
basically he got traded to what is it Al
next year which is the Arab team and
they have a law in Saudi Arabia or yes
they have a law in Saudi Arabia that
says hey if you're not married you can't
live together yeah it's called Sharia
law yeah I mean that's what some people
call it some people call it you know the
the modest rules yeah no one calls it
that nobody but they broke the rules
wrists
[Laughter]
okay so let's just talk about it let's
just talk about it okay
um
I was told that this law doesn't really
apply to foreigners yeah but it's a fun
way of making Ronaldo to go like he's so
impactful he could get them to change
Sharia law that's kind of crazy
oh I was actually looking at it from
Southeast point of view which I was just
like yo the Middle East is coming for
the like PR Crown almost like the way
we've always kind of looked at a place
that's like inaccessible and we'll go
travel to Europe or America or wherever
the Middle East is going to become a big
tourist destination I think and I really
think they're they're using all of their
wealth and just buying positive PR in
the best way
you're getting Ronaldo they've got the
World Cup that's the mo I don't think
it's an accident that got they got the
most popular sport in the world to have
their World Cup in the Middle East you
know what I mean like then let's get the
most popular player maybe second to come
to our league we'll pay him 400 million
dollars money means nothing to us
because we have so much oil money and
now it's invested in everything it's
just making money we're the richest
place in the world and now it's gonna
and then we'll you know we'll tweak the
laws enough that you guys will Overlook
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] we're doing and be
like let's just go visit the Middle East
now
for everybody that was like yo the West
has been ruined by capitalism and all
these other things and they have no laws
they have no the not laws but they have
no morality they've lost their virtue
now that you're seeing Middle Eastern
countries start to sacrifice some of
their morality and laws and virtue for
capitalism can they really question how
it's happened in the West
or is this is this just a natural
process is it is it almost like some
[ __ ] would be like yo I told y'all so
you stay in the west is so different
you're going to be here too in 30 years
40 years I think it's very easy for
those of us without money to talk about
how money corrupts you and how dare you
and then when money gets given to you
you're like oh yeah this is just being
corruption is fun yeah it probably got
like conservative commentators in Saudi
Arabia like we can't let this happen
like we're gonna backslide we're gonna
like [ __ ] and this is slippery slope
they let this happen they're gonna let
this happen but Mark you don't think
that the state who's paying for that is
going to allow there to be dissent right
they're going to say yo shut your
[ __ ] mouth you're excited about it
don't bring it up at all here's a couple
million exactly yes but if people are
seeing like this whole thing backsliding
and all of a sudden like little things
get chipped away and like the whole
country becomes immodest and it's not a
secular country or it's not a religious
country anymore Etc I think there's
gonna be people that are like not We're
not gonna have like the way we have it
in America or what yeah I just I wonder
if they can maintain their country
without oil eventually they run out of
oil can you just be a
strictly religious country without some
incredibly lucrative commodity to prop
it up I don't know if you can well
that's what I I wish I like you started
Sergeant but like you can with oil money
because you can tell people do whatever
the [ __ ] they want because you're paying
for their lifestyle or subsidizing it
and everybody's living kind of good they
got their Apartments taken care of like
I think even in all the emiratis don't
even pay for rent so it's like yeah
they're gonna do whatever you say well
there's probably a lot of poor religious
countries too though
I don't know exactly which ones but keep
going down there yeah yeah but like
there's got to be countries like in West
Africa yeah that are like deeply
religious but they're they don't have
these natural resources and they don't
got a ton my but my suspicion is like in
those countries you see a lot more of
those citizens breaking the rules
because they got to survive yeah so like
prostitution probably a little bit more
popular at least among like the people
there a little drug thing here and there
yeah yeah maybe more I would say more so
than you see like in the Emirates or
Saudi where there's like a safety net
for those people which is the state
that's probably true I need to finish uh
watching this thing I was watching
something on Qatar listen to what you
said you listen to it with audible it's
way easier you know what I'm out of
credits it's the darndest thing well
maybe you can get another credit okay
maybe see if my credits came in just yet
but go on but they were talking about
how let's say guitar got the World Cup
and like how again they're on this PR
campaign basically they understood oil
money was going to run out years ago so
they gave their wealth to basically like
a hedge fund and they own some crazy
amount like 60 of the skyscrapers in
London they own like their money their
oil might run out but the money from
that oil is growing and growing and
growing they're fine he's not listening
no you're 100 right they do own 60 of
skyscrapers you know what man you were
right [ __ ] right you just took all
the air out of mine
no but the wind out of my style but he
didn't I just repeat exactly no I've
been doing that [ __ ] to my wife
if you get the last line so I know
exactly what you're saying they are
preparing for it and they saw they knew
this back in the day that the oil was
going to run out 100 I heard everything
that you said it's just a very common
talking point so I didn't need to listen
you just said earlier that they're going
to run out of oil so yeah that's
impressive you were checking the
blockchain and listening at the same
time the exact same thing still no
credits so your credits are on the
blockchain I'm telling I think I think
I'm gonna go telling you I'm gonna go
find him
um but but yeah I think that like
they're in a weird situation I think the
reason why they have to buy so much uh
uh real estate is because I think uh
they're not allowed to make what is it
called
interest interest so they have to invest
in actual things because the interest is
Haram yeah well they're going to find
their way to get their money yeah but I
was also thinking like live golf
tournament doesn't seem like it's doing
a lot but that's trying to buy PR World
Cup probably bought some PR how can they
not buy like fund their own NFL sports
watching is that what that terms yeah
but they have so much money football is
the most popular sport in America by far
you could easily tell every NFL player
I'm gonna quadruple your salary let's
see if you want to come on over and they
might have enough money to pull that off
yeah but you know what they won't have
they won't have let me not say easily
but you could theoretically I think what
they won't have and this is important to
sports is identifying with the team I
think it works in a thing like golf
where you identify with the player yeah
fair but like the team is representative
of the city and the city is part of your
identity so you're like that's it I like
you're from Dallas you wanna [ __ ] with
the Cowboys like I'm New Yorker I'm a
[ __ ] with the Knicks regardless like if
if we get to see them well you saw but
like if I see the Knicks win a
championship in my life I was going to
be so meaningful if like I love some
random team and Jetta Saudi Arabia like
yeah but for the individual sports like
for tennis tennis for uh golf F1 Formula
One like all those things where it's or
or F1 is a perfect one because the teams
ain't even really from an area like all
the cars I think are made in um in
England I'm pretty sure all the
engineers and kind of [ __ ] are from up
there okay so yeah those are perfect and
those are just the money games and
that's why you saw so many races and
this last one in the Middle East yeah I
think they had Oman I think they had
did they have Saudi
uh they got Dubai I think they had Dubai
like they had a few Qatar maybe I think
their last race of the year is in the
Middle East right how far would it be if
there's a female F1 driver Drive
well no she just have another person in
the car
yeah that'd be [ __ ] up bro that would
be crazy but she had to wear and I guess
she'd wear a helmet you know yeah the
helmets Yeah that's a burka yeah